bonjour mathieu maintenant le match se
joue sur le terrain diplomatique on l'a
vu
oui effectivement l'open d'australie a
commencé ce matin sans son numéro un
mondial c'est novak djokovic récent
d'autres fabuleuse joueurs et joueuses
donc voilà la navire au courant on peut
dire les places aux jeux maintenant et
mettre fin à toute cette quinzaine de
tension et de broc bondissement et de
procès de 130 détention voilà maintenant
place à place aux plus importants à au
jeu et il ya ce grand chelem qui
commence qu'à commencer d'ailleurs ce
lundi et comment est ce que les
australiens le voit finalement cette
éviction de novak djokovic
il voit d'une guigne bonne d'une bonne
manière on va dire parce que
effectivement melbourne surtout à
melbourne la ville qui a connu le plus
de confinement ces deux dernières années
notre police n'était pas forcément le
bienvenu ici la vie si à notre ami et
connaissant tous et toutes ses
convictions et sachant qu'ils soient
alors on va pas dire qu'il est anti
vaccins me dire qu'il est plutôt
aseptique il est plutôt sceptique à la
vaccination donc les australiens voix
salvin d'un bon oeil le prennent avec
avec joie j'ai plein d'amis autour de
moi qui m'ont confié voilà on ne voulait
pas djokovic ne voulait pas ici parce
que pourquoi lui ne se ferait pas
vacciner pendant que nous on
nous imposait une demande de nous
vacciner deux fois trois fois et à de
subir tous ses atouts ses confinement
qu'on a qu'on a subi
ces dernières années vous me voyez
plutôt mauvaise et c'est arrivé de novak
djokovic
d'ailleurs on le surnomme novax c'est ce
qu'on a entendu aussi les australiens
qui ont été assez exemplaire c'est vrai
vous disais en matière de restrictions
sanitaires
oui effectivement alors là pour le coup
tout ce qui est à centres de vaccination
tout ce qui est en matière sanitaire on
a fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts on à dire qu'on a souffert
mais ça a été ça a été de l'on voit de
longues semaines de l'ong jours sans
pouvoir profiter vraiment de la vie donc
voilà maintenant c'est cet open
d'australie arrive dans une période prix
moi de fait même s'il ya des des limites
dans les stades maintenant la la crise
de le la le kobe de redoublent redouble
ici ici en australie donc oui beaucoup
d'efforts et encore beaucoup d'efforts à
faire ces prochaines semaines ces
prochains mois on sait pas trop comment
comment on va pouvoir sortir de cette
situation mais faut vraiment que tout le
monde fasse un effort de son côté et
c'est pour ça également que que novak
djokovic connaît reconnaissable à sa
position sur sur le bac ça
c'est pour ça qu'en ou plus pas mal
d'australiens ne voulait pas trop le
voir venir maintenant c'est les
gouvernements qui vont qui vont en
parler puisque la serbie a fait part de
sa colère on va en parler évidemment
dans nos prochaines éditions merci
beaucoup mathieu plestan pour toutes ces
précisions en direct d'australie ce
matin